hey guys Peter Brown here with the game  spot news update Xbox users rejoice for  your free games for August have been  announced and low they are good active  xbox live gold members can look forward  to two games each for Xbox 360 and xbox  one Xbox one owners will be able to grab  Crimson Dragon and strike suit zero on  August first when they will replace  July's free games guacamelee and max the  curse of brotherhood make sure to  download both of those if you haven't  already Crimson Dragon is an on-rails  shooter and strike suit zero is a space  combat sim both are regularly priced at  twenty dollars unlike xbox one owners  who can download both games all month  Xbox 360s owners month is split in half  from August first to August fifteenth  you can download motocross madness  normally ten dollars and from August  sixteenth to August thirty-first you can  grab this honored which is normally  twenty dollars for more xbox related  news stay tuned to gamespot com